[Music]
what comforts that to William whose
mother's dead because of the bad
decisions that you've made my trail of
bodies doesn't include my own brother
[Music]
[Applause]
it is on everybody this is gonna be my
Oliver versus Diggle video obviously
that was only part of the episode but
that's really what they hype this up as
this is gonna be them fighting it out
and obviously big twist at the end so
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet because maybe you
saw that Diggle coming in the distance
maybe you didn't see it coming but I
feel like they're setting this up for a
big season 7 twist like everything just
doesn't go back to normal and be happy
during season 7 after what's been
happening the last couple of episodes if
you are finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the DC
videos obviously we have a whole bunch
of stuff with Titans that's getting
ready to drop real soon too
so instead of doing this normal top 10
style I'll just go through the episode
but it'll still be like my top 10 video
but you kinda have to call this season
of arrow a series of shockingly bad
decisions that'll be like the new title
for the entire series run when it
eventually goes off the air like you can
kind of see early in the episode they
did a good job of leading you along so
you know why it is they build to that
fight like you can see the way that
Oliver reacts when Felicity says maybe
you should talk to Diggle and he's like
he's fine I don't need to talk to him
he's a dude he gets it he's not the
green arrow I'm the green arrow
if you thought Oliver felt weird during
the episode I think they wrote him extra
insensitive so that they would build to
this much faster but I'm so happy that
they did not drag it out for a couple
more episodes they had their fight they
made up but eventually Diggle comes
around to the more logical idea that
it's not being the green arrow that he's
upset about it is Oliver decisions in
general because like there's that big
WTF moment out in the field where Diggle
almost shoots that perp before that girl
who's also working for Diaz big twist
takes him out before he can give up any
information I'm loyal to Diaz not to
this guy who's also working for Diaz if
it wasn't such a crazy moment I would
have laughed out loud because they're
just layers upon layers to how Diaz has
taken the city and I think they wanted
to get that across with the big twist at
the end where it seems like black siren
is still on the take and she gives the
DEA and the old police chief the idea to
indict Oliver with extra charges like
this is just more evidence
that he's the green arrow because he
doesn't want us to investigate him there
were a couple really big WTF moments
that I felt like we're not good like oh
are they really going to do this one of
the funnier ones was the idea that black
siren could become a lawyer just by
reading a couple of laurels old
textbooks for the last couple of hours
like literally the episode takes place
over the course of a day maybe two days
if you want to be generous it's like
they're trying to tease her for a
redemptive arc she tries to protect
Quentin a little bit but she's still
kind of on the take with DES and then
they're doing it and doing vertigo at
the same time like doing drugs while
having sex at the end of the episode so
clearly she's still crazy town banana
pants but I think they want to get her
character to the place where it's more
plausible that you believe that she
would work at least a little bit with
team arrow during season seven because I
still think she's gonna be around during
season seven but the sort of backdoor to
that is Diaz taunting her with being her
true self like you're not this person
you're not this Laurel from Earth one
who's really good hanging out with her
family helping these friends out you're
above the law don't study the law so she
seems kind of upset when he says that
like she actually does kind of want some
of these things that they're offering
her on earth one like this nice life it
seems kind of nice I think that
compromise that is that she still acts
like a total [ __ ] but she still helps
them out every once in a while there's
lots of crazy theories about her
becoming another version of the Black
Canary I don't know if they would take
it that far
they've killed so many Canaries on this
TV show I don't know that they would
take it one step further to kill Dinah
circling back around to that fight
between Diggle and Oliver because that
sort of crossed over the entire episode
like you have the build-up then you have
the actual fight then you have sort of
the fallout where Diggle quits the team
at the end of the episode the funny
thing about the middle of that is when
he goes to visit Lyla and she done it
gives him the explainer and talks him
through it and he comes to the
conclusion that it's not being the Green
Arrow that he's upset about she's the
one that actually gives him the idea or
helps him arrive at the idea that it's
Oliver's leadership that he's really
pissed off about so damn Lyla taking a
shot at Oliver being a bad team leader I
think it depends on how you feel like
Oliver's made decisions the past couple
of seasons before season six started
Stephen Amell was answering questions
about how he'd be affected by the
Prometheus arc prometheus basically
showed him
all of his mistakes so like how was
Oliver gonna learn from that and move
forward the conclusion that Stephen
Amell came to is the idea that being
this deep in the series
how would Oliver be reacting to
different situations like would he be
acting like season 1 oliver season 2
where would he be more calculated more
considerate making decisions like a hero
that's been a hero for several years but
the way that they set this up in this
episode Diggle is basically dragging him
back to that Prometheus mud like
remember all that stuff that Prometheus
said that you did wrong and how you hurt
everyone around you I'm gonna remind you
of that and throw it in your face in the
only problem I have with this like it
makes sense that Diggle would eventually
get pissed off with some of the stuff
that Oliver does is that Diggle thought
that he could do a better job than
Oliver Diggle as a soldier they reminded
you that several times during the
episode that doesn't mean that he's a
general Oliver is the general he calls
the shots which is why it was a little
weird that Diggle was upset that Oliver
wasn't backing his play so Diggle was
all over the map for about the first
half of the episode but I do really like
the idea that they brought it back
around to all the stuff that he was
doing at the beginning of the season -
like he was doing all that jingle-jangle
we made fun of it there were so many
memes and then they just dropped it like
it was suddenly gone like oh we're gonna
give you a chip it's gonna fix you it's
like the Felicity fix like you go from
not walking at all like being the
wheelchair hero to immediately getting
up and just walking around like it's no
big deal because of some special
technology and that is what you call
network television like how long does
the hero have to be hurt like do we have
to drag this out for a couple more
episodes the funny thing that Marc
Guggenheim said behind the scenes - is
that sometimes they'll get network notes
about that like when characters get hurt
or they get shot with guns like how many
scenes have to go by before the
character can be back to their old self
but throwing Williams dead mother in
Oliver's face that is some dirty pool
all of it like I love the look on
stephen amell face here - because this
is very clearly the setup to a wrestling
match so you're just waiting for the
bell to ding like ding ding all right it
is on let's go the thing I think Stephen
Amell does really well is that moment
before the explosion
like he's so upset that he's
expressionless so I feel like he does
that really well like there are certain
scene
that I feel like he's more suited for
than others it really crazy stuff like
this is his bread and butter which
probably has something to do with him
being a lifelong wrestling fan so just
let me know what you thought in general
of the wrestling episode of arrow and
what you think this is going to lead to
because they're basically tearing
Oliver's life down around him you can be
the green arrow or you can be the mayor
you're stretching yourself too thin
which I do feel like comes from a place
of logic I think the idea is is that
we're gonna get to the end of the season
is gonna be plainly obvious that he is
the green arrow to everyone if it wasn't
already by at the end of this episode
that he's either going to have to come
out to the city and say I am the green
arrow like heavies I am Iron Man moment
or he's going to have to get rid of Diaz
and then leave the city completely he's
not supposed to be the mayor for like
ten more years there's a ticking clock
on his administration even if he wasn't
under indictment but the big question is
is if they did leave star city where
would they go to where they just
straight up go to Seattle like Seattle
is a big location for green arrow in the
comics but there been a lot of times
where he's just traveled around like
hard travel and hero is one of the most
iconic stories I don't think they would
do something like that I think if they
actually did have him leave Star City
you would still have some scenes in Star
City but he would travel around and stay
in one place for a period of episodes
but the problem with a lot of this
though is is it like you know who the
green arrow is Oliver Queen is the green
arrow so at no point did you ever feel
like Diggle had any claim on being the
green arrow so a lot of the storyline
felt a little bit weird I think they
just want Oliver to be by himself alone
against all of the city that Diaz
controls so that you wonder how the hell
is he gonna solve this situation but
what'll happen is is there'll be some
new DC this weekend obviously a bunch of
New Avengers some new Dragonball I don't
know if any of you arrow fans are big
Dragon Ball fans but it turns out like
half of my channel or huge Dragon Ball
fans so that's kind of like a new
Saturday thing for me
but you can click here for brand-new
infinity war and click here for
brand-new flash thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight